(sloshing)
- [Narrator] Until 60 years ago,
all soy sauce was made like this
and it tasted totally different.
But there's a small island
off the eastern coast of Japan
with a town center called
the Country of Soy Sauce.
Here, despite a government ordinance
to modernize production,
a small group of people
continue to make it the traditional way.
(light music)
Yasuo Yamamoto is one of those people.
(upbeat music)
(speaking in foreign language)
Yamamoto isn't doing this alone.
A few of the people who help him,
Mr. Sakaguchi, carpenter and craftsman,
Ms. Takahashi, head assistant,
Ms. Taguchi, head of shipping,
Ms. Yoshioka, in charge
of soy bottle labeling.
Oh, and this is our cab driver.
He drove us here.
(speaking in foreign language)
Instead of using steel, he
uses large bamboo barrels
and means he has to make himself.
These barrels are the main
differentiating factor
between the soy sauce you know and his.
It ultimately comes down to how
the soy beans are fermenting
inside these bamboo barrels.
(speaking in foreign language)
(sloshing)
Traditional commercial
production of soy sauce
takes only a few months.
But for Yamamoto, it takes much longer.
(speaking in foreign language)
It seems like a lot of work
to go through for soy sauce.
But for Yamamoto,
this is what soy sauce is
supposed to taste like.
So it's all worth it.
(speaking in foreign language)
Yamamoto-san, whose soy sauce is better?
Yours or the big guys?
(speaking in foreign language)
(gentle music)